so hinr tell me why do you want to work
in Consulting this career in Consulting
really always intrigued me and what I
likely had in mind first is just this
learning opportunity of working in so
many different Industries so many
different functions in just such a short
amount of time and I really wanted to
just find out whether this would be
something that I would enjoy which is
also why after my second semester then I
did an internship in IT consulting I
worked on a big sap implementation
project and I did learn a lot of things
there and among the these things that I
learned I found out really a second
thing that I enjoyed so much about
Consulting and this is really working
together with clients from my reflection
so far I think there only very very few
other careers in such a short amount of
time you can talk to so many smart
colleagues but also smart clients and
really help them solve their problems